there are planets we have only dreamed
of worlds we've barely glimpsed
a whole universe that billions will
never get to explore but in a small
desert town in California a new mission
has begun and it's called new space I'm
definitely gonna fly to space it's gonna
be a lot of fun and recognition occurred
there's a trailblazing generation of
entrepreneurs whom the sky is no longer
than Libby's as if huge expanse out
there and there are only a few people
that are going after it governments
don't have the money today but the
private sector does they aim to explore
and exploit the solar system we are
absolutely part of this new space race
and find their fortunes in the Stars
dawn in the Mojave Desert Stu which is
on his daily commute the desert
landscape makes you think differently
it's not hard to imagine what Marsh
might look like you can feel pretty
insignificant in a place like this 13
years ago
EU took over a small civilian airfield
at Mojave Tower Mojave one
what are your ceilings right now under
his leadership it's become known as the
Silicon Valley of space exploration I
believe it is in our DNA to explore and
I would make the case that we're
traveling on spaceship earth right now
and maybe it's time to go outside the
hatch and see what's outside
in 2004 Mojave became the USA's first
commercial spaceport if you look all the
way to the left you see straddle launch
then you have X Core aerospace you have
scale composites and then behind that
you have a cluster of Virgin Galactic
Masten Space and enter orbital and all
of these various space companies that
come to Mojave to test their wares many
of these pioneering firms have set up
shop in primitive hangars dating from
the Cold War they're banking on being
among the first to profit from the
dawning of a whole new era in 2010 the
commercial space industry consisted of
just a hundred companies worldwide there
are now over 800
and by 2030 the industry is expected to
turn over 600 billion US dollars a year
for those who want to strike it big in
this modern-day Gold Rush Mojave is the
place to be the biggest asset out here
is this fabulous reservation of airspace
that's right above us that is completely
dedicated for research flight testing so
if you will we have an elevator to space
one of the frontrunners in this new
space race is Virgin Galactic they aim
to be the world's first private company
taking wealthy passengers to the edge of
space
and Rico Palermo is in charge of
building the craft that will get them
there this is where we're assembling the
second spaceship - here you go it's the
center of the world right now I pinch
myself every day I've had a long-term
passion for space you're probably a you
know qualify as a space geek I guess in
fact my wife and I left Australia in
pursuit of a career in the space
industry verging a rebuilding spaceship
- after a test flight in 2014 ended in
tragedy destroying the craft and
claiming the life of one of its pilots
it's a stark reminder of the dangers
facing the pioneers of commercial space
travel
which parts not fitting a lot of gaps to
visit we're developing a spaceship that
can fly you and me into space and that I
think is gonna be transforming for us
here on earth grounded until their new
spacecraft is ready
Virgin Galactic seemed a long way from
their ultimate goal but that hasn't
stopped them capitalizing on a lucrative
new market 700 people have already
booked their place on spaceship 2
handing over a total of 80 million
dollars
50 meters from Virgin Galactic's giant
hanger the fresh-faced employees of
mustn Space Systems run a very different
operation I'm getting intermittent
telemetry here
I need a reboot they weren't even born
when man last went to the moon but that
doesn't mean they can't aim for it and
all the service plumbing and meat here
and they go down 23-year old engineer
Ben has been working on mastan's Rockets
since leaving college two years ago this
is the propulsion system for a potential
lunar lander we're doing a lot of things
that that no one else is doing you know
like the pioneers so I guess yeah we're
venturing on the frontiers of space and
it takes a big part to fix fix something
that I must do right the first time so
Ellen started as an intern just last
year it's exciting to be a part of for
sure I'm 23 and very young this is my
first job I'm pretty sure if I worked at
a large company they would not say hey
go build this rocket if there was a
something that was on the moon that I
knew that I worked on that I had a hand
in building that would be incredible
that would be awesome
they may be young but Ellen and Ben are
helping develop cutting-edge technology
their rockets not only go up but also
use artificial intelligence to stop
manoeuvre and find exactly the right
spot to land
so they can be used again and again
anyplace there's not a runway there's
not enough air for wings to work this is
the sort of technology that you're gonna
need to have overseeing this
enthusiastic workforce as chief
executive Shaun Mahoney today he's come
to watch the test launch of their latest
rocket when we're flying and not
entirely sure that I breathe
we need this test to go well so that we
know the vehicles ready for the customer
has shown up in a couple weeks
Mastan doesn't rely on external
investment the company is run as a
profit-making business their customers
include NASA and they have a three
million dollar contract with a US
Department of Defense
we are absolutely part of this new space
race this isn't just get there it's find
a way to get there so that you can stay
there so that you can keep going there
this isn't a one-shot business anymore
we're looking to build a sustainable
business that will carry on over time
with the test launch one hour away
adding in the team carry out their final
checks Roger that on our way
just down the road another company's
betting on the confidence of youth to
help send people to space in charge of
the propulsion system for their radical
new rocket is 26 year old engineer
Jeremy Voight
this rocket engine is kind of my baby
I'm definitely gonna fly with it
everybody in the company gets to fly to
space and it's pretty cool that I get to
build the engines that are gonna take me
there
Ike school has been developing their
engine for the last seven years there
are no experts in the field there aren't
textbooks that say when I do it this way
this is how you run all of these lines
and make sure that everything is this
size and you started in this way none of
that exists so we have to make all that
up if the test is successful Jeremy will
be one step closer to his ultimate dream
reaching the cosmos red team spill
bucket position under fuel-air pleat
line it's an adrenaline rush to flip the
switch and actually start the system
running patrol peel open push
all right do cold flow 10 9
chill
lux Prime six five four three two let's
see me have no Drive yes all switches
are off and safe
I want to vent tanks I want to look at
data you always have to be prepared to
fail I'm honestly really not
disappointed nothing got damaged all of
my friends are still here that's all
great and we're gonna continue to do
more stuff today is not over yet
if you walk in these hangars they're
kits they're not old guys like me
they're kits and you see the sparkle in
their eye whether they succeed or fail
they have the will to try you know we're
explorers out here we're innovators we
endorse the taking a risk and in doing
so sometimes it comes with failure
I don't care how many times you go
through this sequence my heart rate goes
up a little bit in ohms with every test
launch the entrepreneurs at Mojave
shoulder the risk of failure
but their eyes are on the potential
rewards perilous
if they can perfect technology like
these precision landing Rockets a
multitude of new business opportunities
beckoned from asteroid mining to moon
colonization and beyond just another day
in Mojave yeah yeah thank you sir this
is the technology being demonstrated
right here that is how humans will first
set foot on Mars it may be ours it may
not be ours
but when humans go to Mars vertical
landing is how it's going to be done
and our hope is that over the next
generation thousands will have the
opportunity to go to space because it
when you talk to the people who have
been there changed profoundly changed
from that experience they realized just
how fragile earth is
I think it's time to go out there again
to try things that haven't been done
before why not think what we learned
you